our story is so different the whole
company culture is so different than I
think for us it's an advantage set the
two of us like young female twins come
and do a pitch holder then like your
standards
maybe pour of like a certain age or
wearing suits I think we just stand out
more so it's a certain so my name is
Raisa the house this is my twin sister
Joyce together of your finest of double
dutch and we do a range of p.m. tonal
colors and mixers with 28 years old and
we come from the Netherlands double edge
of the range of premium hams and natural
and more innovative tonic waters a
mixers they are specifically developed
to drink with higher quality genes but
also vodkas tequila's and we just want
to offer a bit more excitement and
innovation into the mixer and tonic
water industry so what is different
about double dutch is or research of
developments behind the recipes are
really different so they're all based on
molecular pairings so we have flavours
like cucumber and watermelon and
pomegranate and basil a cranberry and
ginger so really offering different
types of choice to consumers because the
Netherlands is the birthplace of gin we
kind of grew up with a big passion for
better quality spirits and better
quality drinks especially when we came
to London and we moved here five years
ago we thought there's such a
penalization and Crafts movement in the
spirits industry and especially in the
gin markets but then choice of tonic
waters and mixes was really boring
we just thought to bring more exciting
flavors into the markets we always did
like small entrepreneurial things that
we were younger so we used to when we
were like very young like five years old
we used to sell flowers on the beach
like we would make like paper flowers
and then I sell them and then we used to
have like a corn shop on the streets
where we like we take corn from the
farmers and then sell that we really
don't really have like separate family
and we're glad to think it's so
interconnected to each other but that's
also really amazing because we go to on
holidays together and we can speak it by
double dutch we can also have like fern
or like go to parties together I think
that's really
it's geographical expansion is very
important first so this year we're going
into very big in South Africa Southeast
Asia is very important and going to more
into the u.s. also gonna set up a couple
of more manufacturing plants and I think
growing the team developing very
exciting flavors so I think that's very
fun and just building the company
further I'm going to domination
[Music]